it's really pretty simple try not to go
like this all the time my name is Dewey
Bartlett I'm the mayor of the city of
Tulsa have been mayor for about three
years the fiscal situation when I walked
into office was pretty interesting it
literally was December 7th Pearl Harbor
Day our Director of Finance came in with
a very concerned look on his face and I
said hey Mike what's up and he said we
got a problem we need to save about 10
million dollars over the next couple of
months otherwise we're going to be out
of cash the previous administration
already had to use up most of our cast
reserve at the rate of spending we were
on track with we would have probably had
to file for bankruptcy it certainly got
us focused on how to run a government
better trying to prioritize on things
that the government really should do and
also make a decision on what a
government really doesn't need to do
might be nice to do it but do we
actually have the expertise to do it
first of all and we have the funding to
do it many times the decisions are made
just to cut everybody's budget and not
to cut specific portions of the budget
that really aren't necessary but it was
done with the understanding that we were
not going to raise taxes I've met some
terrific people very very solid
individuals that are mayors of all of
our cities in this country and they said
well we just think it'd be easier just
to raise raise the taxes and the fees in
my view it's not a very smart way to do
it because you're just kicking the can
down the road you really have to
approach it from a way that what we're
going to do the next time things get bad
we gave our police and fire departments
a choice to either cut their salaries
and benefits for a period of time with
the understanding that they would be
restored or if they wouldn't do that
then we'd have to lay some people off
our fire department grumbled but they
agreed to the suggested changes in their
salaries and benefits structure but our
Police Department didn't on
fortunately next day ahead lay 150 of
them off and that's a tough day but it
was necessary our management review
office has been extremely successful
they have demonstrated tens of millions
of dollars of savings over a five-year
period of time projected but immediate
savings as well we saw a lot a lot of
trucks and cars that never moved in up
in the parking lot a nice to always ask
what's the deal here why you know there
why aren't they being used i see people
going to work but the cars aren't going
anywhere so i went out one day and on a
weekend i bought two or three dollars
worth of pennies i heard about this that
a somebody elected official i think in
new york state did this went out and i
put pennies on the tires came back a
week later of the group that i saw
almost a hundred cars had not moved
we've sold about five six hundred cars
and trucks we don't need them anymore we
were not required to buy a whole lot of
police vehicles for one year so that
saved as several million dollars right
there plus we've now have a much better
system of evaluating who needs trucks
when where and why well I became there
we looked at the property we owned and
that we had I mean a list of properties
that were not being used for anything
just accumulating property so we
embarked on a process to get rid of all
this property so we start selling it off
the real poster child to get rid of was
our old city hall we'd already moved out
of the building had been in this
building now for a couple of years our
old city hall was falling into disrepair
we were still spending about half a
million dollars to try to keep it open
and available for use because we were
trying to sell it but we were getting
absolutely no buyers nobody wanted to
buy it so we put it out for public
auction and we sold it got a million
bucks for it got rid of it and that
saved us a considerable amount of money
but now what's great about it is it's
now in private hands it's paying ad
valorem taxes the school system loves
that
is being converted into a hotel has
restaurant will have restaurant
facilities etc will get sales taxes off
of that it's going to be employing over
a hundred people we don't need to be in
the in the land land banking business
we're getting rid of more of our
property get it back and upon the on the
on the tax rolls where it ought to be
public-private partnerships using the
private sector is a terrific opportunity
privatization scares a lot of a lot of
public employees but we said we we want
we think that you the our employees
should be in a position since you know
this better anybody else you should be
in a position to understand a bidding
process better and bid your services
against the private sector so that's
what we did building that we're in now
is the one that we use as a guinea pig
about eight different companies bid on
the operations of this building our
employees won by about a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars they underbid
everybody under the lowest bid by that
amount of money so they got the job we
then said to our employees if you can
find further savings that are verifiable
real true savings you can put some money
in your back pocket for that savings you
can keep about twenty-five percent of
whatever you save and that god I'm very
perked up and we wanted people to
understand that Tulsa once again was a
real bastion for private enterprise and
entrepreneurship and a great place to be
we wanted to roll out the red carpet not
the red tape city government can't do
everything for everybody and you have to
be able to say no there's somebody else
that can do it better we position
ourselves that when the economy does
take off that the city of Tulsa is going
to be at the front of the line for the
business creation opportunities that
this country desperately needs
you